what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down today I have a special
guest on the show Welcome Aaron pizy how
are you okay thank you um okay I have a
question so you started the first men's
rights or men's abuse shelter in England
correct I started to begin with i in 71
I started a woman's shelter the first in
the world really oh that was the first
women's shelter too I had no idea wow in
London and uh
the and the shocking thing for me in
1971 is was no literature I'm I started
trying to look for help because no one
as far as I couldn't find anything
there's nothing written no books nothing
about domestic violence and of course
it's been with us since time of Memorial
it was never ever discussed anywhere wow
um but I became aware very early on
partly because of my own family dynamics
that me women were just as violent as
men and that's what caused the big split
where because you identified as a
feminist before that right no I was
feminist for about 5
minutes and then actually what I saw
because I the first meeting I ever went
to uh and it was amazing I've been
married for something like 10 years and
I had never gone out on my own so if you
think about it in 1970 women didn't you
went out in couples and so I went to
this first meeting and as I was walking
up stairs there were these mou posters
and I was bitterly disappointed cuz I
knew a lot of about that subject asz my
parents my father was in the old
Consular service and my parents were
captured in in sin by the Communists
under a house arrest for three and a
half years we didn't see them and for a
long time we didn't have any news we
didn't know whether they were alive or
dead wait could could you I'm sorry
could you explain that actually that was
in my notes you were born in China born
in China it's born in s out that's what
it was called in the old days okay and
your why were your parents there cuz my
father was in the old Consular service
what is is that a Consul is represents
the people uh uh of England and the
consul is his job is to take care of the
English contingent for instance in in
Shanghai okay and then you didn't see
him for three years because they took
him no what this is this is 1947 okay
was I think it was 19 it probably 49 was
when they my parents had been sent back
to jinsen in China okay as a diplomat
posting and the the Chinese Communists
were taking over over and they took over
my parents home and other other British
people and they were all under house
arrest for three and a half years so we
were about 11 I say we my twin sister
and myself were about 11 and a half when
this happened and we were in boarding
schools oh and then in Holiday Homes wow
so at 11 years old your parents were put
on house arrest so you didn't see your
parents for 3 and 1/2 years and you were
in boarding school wow what was that
like that must have been so like were
you scared you wouldn't see them again
or like what did you even understand
what was going on well you know nope
it's something I talked to my twin
sister about cuz we're 84 now nobody sat
us down and explained what was happening
the nuns just went on with everyday life
we knew nothing about anything but
eventually my mother managed to get some
letters through to us so we knew they
were alive obviously she couldn't say
anything cuz they were heavily censored
but at least we knew they were alive and
they had my brother with them as well he
was 6 years younger than we were and so
they were in China and you were in
England yeah London well well noors it
and and so in the in the term time we
were in in a in a convent school and in
the holidays we were a place called St
Mary which is a a a lovely lovely old
manor house with 240 acres of land and
this very eccentric woman called Miss
Williams okay ran it and we were the
other children were all whose parents
were abroad so we went there for
holidays wow so you you basically were
in this boarding school nobody told you
where your parents were you haven't seen
we knew they were in China but we didn't
know anything else till several years
and then my mother I said she managed to
get a letter through to us so we knew
that they were alive and then it says
here you went to South Africa that's
ages before when we we have to go right
back to when we were born in in in uh
China in singal my parents were then
moved to Shanghai and then the Japanese
came in and so we were on the last boat
out of China and that's how we ended up
in in in South Africa and we were
refugees when I say we my mother and my
twin sister and myself we were refugees
and we stayed in costat in South Africa
and my father was posted up to Beirut
and eventually we joined him wow you've
literally lived everywhere you know it's
funny when um my intern gave me like the
notes that you were from China and I
told him I was like this has to be wrong
she's not from
China yeah my Chinese name was jeta
which means eldest sister and my twin
who's three years three minutes younger
than I it's called m means little sister
did you speak Chinese at all apparently
fluently really well yeah because we
were with our with the with the servants
most of the time my mother wasn't much
of a mother your mom wasn't fact she was
a crap mother really she was a it sounds
like you were kind of from like an upper
class family it seems like no no I think
let's call it aspiring middle class oh
aspiring my father certainly wasn't and
he made he was good he never made any
bones about it he never had an H to his
name very very brilliant eccentric
emotionally completely unstable but a
very brilliant man and The Misfortune on
that he he married my mother because the
two of them were completely incompatible
well when I think of boarding school in
the US that's like kind of a rich
person's like thing that's that's kind
of why I the same here but I would think
what happened would would be because
they were under house arrest had no
choice the foreign office would have
paid the fees right so you and you said
your mother was she she wasn't much of a
mother well she was she was a very
beautiful narcissist your mom was a
narcissist oh yeah classic how and of
course you see it goes back to something
I've always said it's
generational domestic violence is
generational and and not only
generational but also the dysfunction is
generational so when you looked by and
this is why I first started thinking
about it because if you looked about my
father's history and my mother's history
you would see that their strategy I call
it strategies for survival because we
all as children have to develop
strategies for survival sometimes you
know it's fine because the family is
warm and loving and and all the rest of
it but for an awful lot of us it isn't
like that and so my twin sister she she
hibernated really that's how she dealt
with the stress uh you know and I I was
just very violent the first book I wrote
was called infernal child because nobody
knew what to do with me CU I was so
violent you so my strategy was to fight
really you don't come off you don't come
off like that I've mellowed I'm
so your was your mom abusive towards
your father they fought all the time my
mom did a lot of crying and and took me
till I was 16 to realize she set up an
awful lot of the fighting and they they
were just belligerent and they fought
verbally but she beat me very badly
because she I often think it was because
I looked so much like my father and she
really hated him well I've oh my gosh I
and I um did a show with I don't know if
you've heard of Jesse Lee Peterson um is
another YouTuber but that's what he said
he said that mothers don't like kids
that don't look like them he
particularly if they look like a man
they dislike yeah that's what he said
too and so that's what kind of got you
interested in the whole domestic
violence stuff was because you saw
growing up I mean maybe she wasn't she
was abusive towards you and your sister
not towards my sister mind you I mean
you know it what nobody ever as I kept
saying you know this one occasion when
she lost it completely and she had an
ironing called and she beat me with it
and when I went to school the next day I
said to the teacher cuz you could see
the welts on my legs with with blood
dripping with scabs by then and uh the
teacher said well no wonder she beat you
you're such a horrible child but nobody
ever stopped to think and they don't do
it now hey hang on a minute children
aren't born back and so it's actually in
my experience I think that mothers are
more abusive than fathers typically when
it comes to Children yeah like and don't
and I get angry because what tends to
happen if you say that oh yes but that's
because mothers are with the children
much more than they are but it's not
it's not that a normal woman does not
beat a child ever you might lose your
temper and slap but usually a normal
woman will apologize and know slapping
is not the answer right but where you
get a violent woman like my mother do
you think that women are more nurturing
than men different way I think I think
women are actually physically more
nurturing emotionally more nurturing
I've always think of women you know
internalizing in the inside the home
with the children and the father's role
which I think is quite healthy is he's
the external world he protects he looks
after he takes care think they're
different roles MH and how did you see
those roles change over time like you
said you're 84 it's always interesting
talking to people that have like lived
through a couple different Generations
because like growing up like most moms
worked you know what I mean like I
didn't really see many stay-at-home moms
in general I didn't really see for me
very few rich women worked cuz they had
nannies really if they wanted to yeah
they had Choice yeah but but on the
whole no I mean the Homemaker was what
you what you you in the convent I was in
this is an example we were taught to Da
socks for our husbands and if you didn't
Dar it properly he might get a blister
so it was unded and you have to stop
again I was not enamored of the idea of
a husband who was going to get
blisters um so then you started the
first Domestic Violence Shelter by
accident I always said this if I don't
what was going to happen I'd have run
away you would have run away yeah I
would yeah awful nobody ever they always
see the Glamorous side of it oh yeah you
started the nightmare when I opened a
little Community Center I was thrown out
of the feminist movement here in England
and I was banned from all the so-called
collectives wait why because I told them
that I didn't want to be a communist our
first meeting if I told you with the
chairman M for things MH and then the
first question I was asked was why was I
there and I said primarily because I was
lonely and isolated because women in
those days you were you were home with
your children and you're the only only
other women you're likely to meet the
the wives of your colleagues your
husband's colleagues and my husband was
in television the kind of women I was
likely to meet was other television
wives and I wanted a much bigger world
than that I wanted I didn't see why
because we had children we had to be
excluded which is what happened in the
71 and the 80s all of a sudden you had
these children and then nobody wanted to
know you they weren't going to ask you
anywhere was particularly lonely at
weekends because that other women had
their husband's home and didn't want you
around there with their children when
after I'd been told that my problem
wasn't that I was lonely and isolated my
problem was that I was oppressed by my
husband I thought I looked at it all and
thought hang on a minute there's M
posters we told that we had to meet in
collectives M we were told to call each
other comrades so I just well in that
case if you're serious nothing to do
it's not a women's movement and actually
I don't know about the American
situation but certainly in England it
was not anything to do with the women's
movement for women or for our betterment
it was actually a Marxist movement and
one of the things they've always said is
that if you want to destroy the family
convert the women first so it was it was
and and I went on and actually this
little group that I had that we we were
all at home with children I remember us
standing up on these State on these
platforms and saying look you know we
love our husbands we're married we've
got children we're asking for a
different alternative so we aren't
isolated that's all and we got screamed
out so I got book I got a letter
basically saying I was not allowed to go
into any Collective do you still have
the letter yep I've got it Liberation
hand on it and everything and so I and I
badger houndo with my little group and
they gave us a derel tiny house as a
meeting place for women and children had
two rooms upstairs two rooms downstairs
an outside lbe and a kitchen and we were
in business really for about 6 months
lots of women came to us who wouldn't go
near social services or any of those
kind of
organizations and they'd come for all
sorts of problems and a lot of them just
like me they were lonely and isolated
and one of the things any woman could do
was to have a key so she had her her
place she could come and go she wanted
to and we had an upstairs one of the
robins was an upstairs office with a
typewriter and a telephone and we began
the business of sorting out what people
needed in our area and then the first
woman Kathy I'll never forget she came
in and she was Blue from her neck down
to her waist while he beaten her with a
chair leg and carefully so that no one
could see the bruises and uh I took her
home that night because there was nobody
in the little house my husband came home
from work and he said anything happened
today I said no not very much there's a
a lady sleep upstairs on OS my son
amos's top bunk that was Kathy and she
was the first woman that came in and
then it was terrifying because the local
newspaper got hold of the fact that
something was happening it was quite
near us and there was a trail of women
turning up and they they published a
story and women just it was terrifying I
mean there were they were the do the
door just never stopped and so basically
then that was how it started was then
you started having women coming in that
were
beinging then almost immediately coun
Council Alderman King who was the Oldman
of uh took out warrants for my arrest
you got a warrant for your arrest for
starting an abuse shelter from the very
beginning yeah why because I was
overcrowding what he didn't do was to
say what can we do to help and I would
have said every burrow needs to open a
refuge which I tried saying but nobody
wanted to it was such a fight you've no
idea so what's happened to the women's
shelters um because I I'm just I have a
question kind of from the point of view
it seems like a lot of them now it's
like a political agenda it is not but I
knew that was going to happen because as
you know I I was kicked out of the
women's movement right and I knew as
soon as I got any funding and this is
1971 remember that they would come
because they the initial uh publications
of of newspapers like the guardian for
instance it's it the Guardians always
been slightly left mhm uh uh uh I knew
that once that happened they they would
come because they in the beginning could
cost you £310 shillings to join £310
Shillings in those days was probably
your whole budget for food for the week
for you and your family so it was a lot
of money and that eventually ran out
because it was no longer fashionable so
that's when I knew and of course Very
quickly we we were supported by the
public who were reading about us the
sending us money and almost overnight
the next one to open and it was a
feminist Refuge now I don't think you
know or most people don't know I might
have told you last time boys over 12
can't go into refuges they can't go to
refugees anywhere boys over 12 when what
I've gathered from the women's shelters
today is that a lot of them advise women
to falsely accuse their husbands of
abuse in order to get more funding and
they have stories based on where the
husband is from so like for example if
he's from Nigeria you know they have one
story he's over controlling because of
the culture and they've basically
expanded and like changed the definition
of abuse where they've included like
emotional abuse where it used to just be
physical yeah and shouting shouting is
abuse why like how did that happen like
did you did you I know you said you
predicted it but did you see the
evolution cuz it sounds like it it
started as like a good thing and and now
it's almost like being used to break up
the family which is what you said in the
beginning well yes because the the
feminist movement is all one of its its
aims has always been to break up the
family because the idea is this and it
was in 1990 the women's Minister here in
England called Harriet Haron had a
policy paper and the policy paper she
she she an anakot who's another uh civil
servant I think very very high up they
what they were saying is that the new
model will be women and children wow who
said that Harriet Harman Harriet Hartman
yeah said that the new policy paper
which you can't find now policy paper
1990 and she says that in it she said
men are not necessarily harmonious to
family life Wow and you're saying all of
this has roots in communism well yes
because that it any whether it's Russian
communist or Chinese communism it's
always been if you if you want to
control men you have to get rid of the
family right because a man will fight
for his family and of his country but
first of all if you want communist
country of any sort or socialist if you
like then you get rid of the family
first um what were what did you figure
out when it came to violence um I think
you have a quote that you said women
women are as capable of violence as men
to think that women are gentle creatures
and that men are violent is the wrong
idea and I think I think that and it's
known because of it's known physically
that in in a Waring situation women
often attack first I think women are
more violent than men um on the whole
yes and certainly certainly
psychologically violent I think if we if
women could like the difference is men
their fists can literally kill somebody
women they can't but I think if women
had equal strength to men I think they
would be just as just as woman put it to
like this to me sorry I'm you're getting
uncomfortable she said you know Aaron uh
she said uh what she said knives are a
great leveler and indeed The Killing
that I saw was usually a knife fight
with where the woman kills the man
certainly I've come across women who are
beaten to death did you see was that
more common than did you say it was more
common than men beating women was women
actually stabbing men no I think I think
you can't say that because it's not a
numbers game right it depends entirely
on what happened in the family then you
have to ask yourself why in if three
children are born into violent families
through no fault of their own they're
affected by the violence okay so two of
them might grow up to be violent and the
third transcend what's the transcending
in my case it was Miss Williams who ran
the children's home she was a by the
time I was nine and I I was a very
dangerous child I nearly drowned a
little girl and I I I I always remember
my parents had gone and we were doing
our first holiday in at with Miss
Williams in her holiday home Miss
Williams was enormous she was about 6' 7
she was huge and weighed God knows how
much she had driven ambulances during
the war she was a golf championship she
she's golf she was brilliant and she was
a magistrate and I took one look at this
woman and it's the first time I ever
respected anybody and that she was my
mentor so I've always known that what
you need is a mentor and in my time I
have been mentor to an awful lot of
children many of whom lived with me and
so and you said if you were to do it
over again you wouldn't do any of it is
that right and then you said that
earlier what I said is if I known what
was coming I'd run away oh it's sorry
it's not not the same
thing so different sorry I don't
remember it's funny because and also you
know people would come up and they'
touch my clothes and and and they'd say
oh you're so like Mother Teresa do you
know Mother Teresa yeah okay and I'd say
yes but she didn't have a drink problem
and they get Terri
offended but why is that you got a lot
of push back like were the feminists
just basically trying to destroy what
you'd built yes that yeah well yes
because they they immediately you can
imagine they immediately saw it as a
funding Prospect and of course here in
England Refuge is is the uh is has is
the Refuge that I created there's also
the national Federation of refuges which
is another organization but the two are
feminist organizations and I think
between the two of them they get
something like 300 million a year wait
and so the organization that you started
got taken over by feminists no was that
hard to watch like I know I know how I
left England I left England that broke
my heart but I knew
look I was so in that the only way I
could rehouse mothers and children was
to become the biggest squatting agency
in England so you could imagine the The
Establishment hated me and I didn't obey
judge's orders if I thought they were
wrong and there was a case where I had
to I had to hide a mother and three
children out against judges orders in a
country that had no uh extradition at
that point it was southern Ireland
southern Ireland didn't have extradition
I I hid her out there that lawlessness
of obvously may be hated yeah well and
I'm thinking like that's just got to be
so sad to watch like your life's work be
taken by an organization that you don't
agree with it is well particularly I
think the thing that's the biggest
stumbling box I've got is that they the
boy's over 30 the women either have to
make other arrangements for him or they
have to stay in the violent relationship
and leave the boy they leave the boy has
to usually stay in the violent
relationship but it you you can't do
that you simply can't it's to me it's
immoral you know the new thing that's
kind of coming about cuz I'd imagine
they don't let the men into the women's
shelter because there's some accus like
I'm just guessing here no no man can
work in the women's shelter any women's
shelter it's completely completely
forbidden and in in our shelter the
mothers and I all agreed that we needed
men and always half the staff and
volunteers were always men right how
else are children going to know good
kind gentle men
right well I was even thinking like um
you're seeing all these stories coming
out now cuz they would always say that
men were like the perverts or whatever
but now you're seeing all these stories
of women coming out where they were the
ones being perverts to young boys yeah
and it's actually so common like I know
just from doing um interviewing so many
people you you just start to hear the
same stories and like so many guys first
sexual experiences with with like a
friend's mother or like a teacher or
something and they're not really
punished for it so it's like they'll
kind of say that the women the men can't
be in these women's shelters cuz they're
so creepy or whatever but if the roles
are reversed like they people don't
really care people do care the children
care you know the idea the idea that you
you know there is this idea and it it's
certainly you know it's for a child who
that is actually molested by an older
adult is somehow particularly if it's a
woman molesting a son somebody else's
son or even their own not their own so
much but it's considered well he's lucky
it's a good experience you know he's
been initiated all this kind of thing we
no it's it's there there is no
difference between molesting as a boy or
a girl it's molestation what I what do
you do looking at the face of a
six-year-old boy who has been molested
and you look into his eyes innocence has
gone that's the worst part of it it
destroys the child's ability to be
innocent and that's why I make it makes
me sick it's so awful to do that to a
child what did you find when it came to
men's abuse victims well that's why I
tried to open a men's house but I keep
saying this then this is the thing that
bothers me hugely that the men the
millionaires who are willing to put
their hands in their pockets for mothers
and children weren't willing to give me
a penny for men's house men do not take
care of each other I've noticed that too
whenever I talk about like men's issues
some of like the rudest people to me are
other men calling them like babies or
like oh they're yeah or they just say
they're not like manly enough or like
they they how you know and they like I
even I did an interview once where I I
told a guy a story about um how a man
basically was falsely accused by his
wife kicked out of his H like the kind
of the textbook Playbook a lot of women
do here where they call the cops on him
kick him out of his own house put him on
child support it takes him 2 years to
even get to court by the time he gets to
court he hasn't seen his kid in 2 years
or a year cuz Co kind of backed it up
and this guy just said if he was really
leading his household that never would
have happened and I'm thinking but
that's why that that's that's because
men I keep saying they don't defend each
other I've always thought men are
scared of women
anyway men are are scared of women
because women have so much power not in
all right not in the outside world you
can say the CEO of a huge company when
he goes home at night he's not a CEO of
anything it depends what mood she's in
it depends whether she' been fighting
with the children it depends on all
these things was it always like that yes
probably but then there's a huge
difference again between women and oh
girls and boys born into warm loving
happy families largely will go on to to
marry warm loving happy wives and
husbands that's the normal but some of
us who came from toxic family
backgrounds like I did you have to be
have help to transcend and with the
women coming into the Refuge of the
first hundred 62 were as violent as the
men they left and those are the ones
that I most had to care for because I
had to design a Therapeutic Community
and to offer and to say to her look you
go straight from frustration and rage go
to rage so as soon as you're upset or
you're crossed there's no middle ground
you declare war on whoever's upset you
there are other ways to handle
frustration and you need to learn them
and that's what we did in the Refuge
what would you teach them the funny
thing to teach them actually to be
vulnerable you don't think about this
but if you come from violent family
where you never know where you are you
never know when violence is going to
erupt or you're going to get yelled at
or screamed at or whatever or hit then
you're always in a state of
hypervigilance and what the Refuge had
to teach as soon as you are frustrated
there are other strategies for survival
and those are ones where you learn to
trust people if for an awful lot of
women coming in they never trusted
anybody in their lives because they were
born into these very dysfunctional
violent families cuz they couldn't trust
the first people that they were supposed
to be able to trust I'm guessing like
their parents could yeah cuz that's
their parents who are violent and
dysfunctional and you said 62 out of a
hundred of the women that came to you
were equally as violent as the men so
why is this narrative pushed so much
that men are the abusers if because
there's money if and i' I've talked to
some of these fous women running
refugees and they just said we're not
sharing the pot they know perfectly well
some of the women coming in a violent
and they victim first sign that she's
violent and they're out on the streets
with the children and you've spoken to
some of these women like behind the
scenes and that's what they'll tell you
we just don't want to share the funding
and it's become so mainstream in the
media now like even I don't know if you
saw that clip a couple of years ago of
the women saying that the man deserved
to have his like genitals cut off
because he cheated and that was like
mainstream everybody was laughing but
I'm like if the rules were reversed
nobody would be laughing if a guy did
that to a woman absolutely and and think
of the horror you know when a genital
mutilation of women in Africa absolute
horror but you could you can say what
you like about men cuz in a way we've
decimated the whole idea of masculinity
we we we we will the claim that you know
masculinity is toxic it's not femininity
isn't toxic it was always part of the
women's movement in those early days and
I'm talking in the early' 70s that the
the part of the push was that women
would force men to become more like
women which to a large extent has
happened oh it totally has happened so
what you've got is feminized men who are
very confused yeah and then masculine
women it's like it's weird when you look
at the young couples it's like the guys
are dressed a little more feminine and
the girls are dressed a little more
masculine yeah was that an go ahead
sorry go ahead I was just going to say
one of the arguments was that that went
very badly wrong I'm just trying to
Betty free down came to the American
Embassy in the in the time I was in The
Refuge and she stood up and said very
bravely she said you know we as
feminists went very badly wrong she said
one of the things we did was to to reach
and that isn't what we should have been
reaching for we have our own power as
women and I think that's very true has
it been weird to watch the change in
culture over the last 80 years been
terribly sad you know and this is going
to sound very weird probably to you but
I regret that my granddaughter who's now
in her 40s never knew in that when I was
in the 50s and I was the teenager in the
50s about 1450 in those days a young boy
would have to ask your father if he
could take you out young boy would bring
flowers box of chocolates and it was
very very innocent boys knew if they got
a girl pregnant they would have to marry
both sides of the family would accept
that would expect it there's a very
different time and I regret that it's
gone and what it's been replaced with is
hookup and it's starting even like
younger and younger now too like you
have kids that are sexually active at
like 13 14 like it's so young I know um
and a lot of times it's not even from
the crazy backgrounds like because
social media is so big it's almost a
bigger influence on the kids than their
own family unit especially the dad yeah
especially if the dad's not in the home
because normally my time usually I mean
you the idea being that you didn't have
any sex till you got married but
realistically it was probably 18 before
you had sex so it's a hell of a jump
from 18 down to to 14 and 14 you know
14-year-old girl is still a baby and the
saddest thing I've talked to midwives
about this is when you've got 14year old
girls or younger having babies CU their
bodies aren't ready for it and neither
are they emotionally either CU it had to
have been such a like I always think
about what the world was like before
like social media TV phones because my
basically my whole existence it we've
always had it um I think I remember
getting a Smartphone when I was like 12
so I mean how I don't know about you I
don't remember a ton before I was 12
like before I was 10 you know you
remember B BS but it was so long ago I
remember yeah I remember um at the
Holiday home Miss Williams would take us
to see a film M uh we weren't allowed to
go see films on our own even even
teenagers so there she she'd sit there
and if any man in the film kissed a
woman she'd stand up scream out
disgusting Mar us out of the cinema very
humiliating it's weird to hear you say
that you started the shelters because of
um loneliness almost because I don't
imag iMed in that time there was more
Community than there is today not in
London there probably would be in the
country but not in in a city like London
not in the city and also particularly
because my husband's job was in
television he was away a lot so it isn't
as though I had anybody to come back to
at night know for him to come back to
there were you know there were weeks
when he wasn't around so that was part
of my isolation and a lot of other women
were that were lonely and isolated party
because for instance all these women and
know the hundreds of them whose and the
children whose fathers are in prison
women love criminals you know they do
bad boys
yeah even then yeah oh
always they say I'm they all say I'm
lying when I say that that women love
criminals no no no no it's absolutely
true why do you think that's more common
from like the backgrounds you were
saying or do you think that's just inate
I just think it's inate there's
something it's the Anarchy in the man
yeah and and and along with a Criminal
Behavior or antisocial behavior of All
Sorts actually yeah there's also that
anarchic side of it which is very
attractive to women I mean what I always
said to women look you make a choice you
look at a man he's marriage material you
look at a man and he's nothing of the
sort if you try and reform him you're
wasting your time yeah but there is this
Instinct in women to reform what were
feminists like back then I remember
staying because I I had time on my hands
because both my kids were at school so I
would go up to they had a um an office
in Po in Poland Street off Shaftsbury
Avenue and so I I was a to secretary and
so I'd offered to go up and work and
answer all the letters and do all the
things some of the administration that
needed doing uh so I went up you know
expecting it to be fairly organized but
it wasn't at all I I just remember being
shocked by the whole thing particularly
as what happened tend to happen is that
as the letters came in and desperate
women from across the country were
sending in three 10 Shillings in in
Cash3 10 Shillings and some of the women
in the office would just rip the
envelopes open and pocket the money and
go off oh they would just keep the money
what
yeah well they just ripped
everybody off wow and would you say
feminism is stronger today or back then
I think feminist is probably stronger
today it's not you know uh no longer
sort of the fashionable thing in the
newspapers every day but it's stronger
in terms that they have now and it's
with I could see this happening from the
very beginning they borrowed it it
really into the whole of the
establishment so majority of lawyers are
now uh women most of them feminists
they're the ones that'll advise women to
claim um domestic violence and they call
it the it's called the Silver Bullet if
you don't get your divorce fast enough
because you claim he beat you you then
say he's molested the children and that
that'll do it he will never be allowed
to see his kids again only has to be an
allegation no proof no proof needed wow
and that's called a silver bullet and
when did you see that pop up like when
did you see it switch the most probably
by the early '90s that's when I was born
if you're
wondering wait so how have women changed
over time for a long time women would
say to me I don't do housework I don't
do cooking and it was this this you know
repudiation and then I think in the
first flush then as women raced up to
get themselves jobs they began to to
recognize that they would that that
women had two jobs women had two jobs
because they had look after the children
and work and isn't as though husbands
suddenly doing half the housework they
weren't so very women found themselves
exhausted and I think they're exhausted
now I almost find that men know how to
do more housework than women these days
so it I like I would say if I talk to 10
women and 10 men in my age group I
almost think that more men would know
how to cook than women cooking yes
probably but they don't cook every day
and it's not always baked beans and fish
fingers is it no I I think that most of
them you like take out now like
the um so you said I have spent my life
trying to help victims of domestic
violence and I've seen the pain and
suffering that it causes it's not a
gender issue it's a human issue it
really is can you tell me more about
that first of all I think you'll find
all the academic figures show that both
men and women are virtually equally
liable to be violent if they're raised
in viol generations of violence not many
will transcend without intervention mhm
that's really what I feel and uh we
don't intervene we don't we in children
in school who are showing very obvious
side of signs of domestic violence in
their background it's ignored nobody
it's still nobody really wants to talk
about it and you said the myth of the
weak woman who has been beaten down by a
powerful man is a myth that keeps women
weak well and also this myth and it does
bother me that women need protecting by
men because they're weak because yes I
do think that that there
the fragile thing I think is trying to
balance what men want and women need
because in the childbearing Years you
are needy as a woman you do need
protecting it's ridiculous to pretend
you don't you do and and and for men I
think one of the the difficulties now is
that women have been so hostile to men
well nearly 50 years there's been this
hostility It's Made Men very afraid of
having anything to do with women I was
at a a a conference a Men's Conference
last week was held here in England and
uh Peter Jord Jordan Peterson was there
but also Warren Farrell he wrote the
book I don't know if you ever heard of
him have you I've heard the name he
wrote the book about boys the very
famous book about boys he is an amazing
man and it was just so interesting to me
to to to be among so many highly
qualified mature adult men and to listen
really again you know to this this
feeling that they're living in a hostile
world and that that the Western world is
hostile to what they call pale stale
pale white stale males or something like
that and it it upset me actually quite a
lot because as women we need those men
to be adult and mature so they can
father children and many of these men
one particular one that I was very fond
of he hasn't been able to see his
daughter since his ex-wife was pregnant
she's never allowed him and he says and
I I said to him well you know you can
there's no no good me saying you know
you could can go to law and get access
to your child he can't afford to to he's
American he can't afford that and and
that's why it goes so very badly wrong
except in the case of physical violence
and emotional violence that both parents
should have 50/50 custody of children
well and it's so common too like the man
that can't see his children I really
think that a dead the deadbeat dad is a
myth um I do too I don't very rely yeah
most men that I know that don't have
access to their children want access and
I don't understand why men don't get
custody if they tend to raise better
children like all of the data says that
single father homes turn out
significantly better than single mother
homes so absolutely does so then why
isn't the bias given to the man I
remember who are who are the majority of
solicitors and they're feminists and how
many judges um 5050 a huge amount of
feminist judges is it's like 5050 with
male and female is it not I could be
wrong but in family courts you see
because majority of an awful lot of male
judges don't do Family Court they say is
something that women do oh so judges
it's more even but I bet if I looked up
Family Court numbers it would probably
be disproportionately women it would be
yeah wow you've seen recently there's um
some judges that have been getting shot
in the news because the guys just like
and that's kind of one thing they don't
really talk about is a lot of these like
crazy men or like these abusive terrible
men are actually men that have been
going through the ringer in family court
and then one day they just like Snap and
go crazy um like one case that I heard
of was in the I think his name was Chris
it was in the midwest this guy that like
freaked out killed his whole family
which obviously that's like a crazy
thing to do but reasoning behind it was
she I guess was taking him through the
ringer in family court she was saying
she was going to call him an abusive
like monster like she was saying she was
going to basically destroy his life and
he just like Snapped and killed
everybody now obviously that's like
awful and I'm not trying to discount it
but they never talk about what led up to
it it's always just he was an abusive
monster I know and and and again they
don't really talk about um male suicide
even though it's four times more likely
for a man to kill himself here in this
country than than than women and nobody
ever talks about the fact that these are
men who are largely from their children
as you say can't see their children lost
their homes lost their jobs and have
have fallen really into a terrible state
of depression and they kill themselves 4
to one and we don't talk about men
suicide when do you ever hear about male
suicide you don't women if the figure
was for women boy would there be a but
the other thing too I have to say is
that if that was a women killing
themselves there'd be huge women's
movement to stop it where are the men's
movement stop it there aren't there
isn't one well and whenever you talk
about men's issues they always find a
way to make it about women well yeah men
are expendable the only time Society
really wants men around is if there's a
war because then they can die even I was
thinking about how um if you say men are
more likely to commit suicide that do
you know what the respon the response
and I'm sure you get this is always will
women try more women manipulate more and
to be honest with you I used to keep
these big you know questionnaires in The
Refuge and one of the questioners is
have you ever tried to commit suicide
virtually every single woman would say
yes but and it it because in those days
the doctors used to hand out pills to
women you go to the doctor you say my
husband beats me he gives you valium
they all came into the Refuge with
masses of Valium that was the the the it
didn't take long actually because it's
highly addictive along with all the
other problems they had they were
addicted to valan and um the difficulty
with with all that is yes women were
more likely to attempt suicide but men
killed themselves and it's still the
same with women it's a cry for help Men
Don't Cry for Help Unfortunately they
would they the figers wouldn't be as bad
as they are yeah and I think men are
more pragmatic about it like um even the
guys that I have interviewed that I
wouldn't be surprised if they killed
themselves it's kind of because they
look at their situation and they think
my reputation's destroyed I've been
fired from my job I can't see my
children what is
where women a lot of times I sometimes I
think it's more attention based where
yeah where they want attention but it
can be a cry for heal yeah you know but
it just kind of goes to show that
whenever you talk about a men's issue
they always make it about women and it
doesn't really matter what it is like if
I say women are like me women are more
likely to leave um and divorce their
husbands and break up the home it's
always like well why did they leave they
must have been an abusive cheating
monster and then I found out that women
around actually more likely to stay with
the abusers yeah this is a whole
different we might do this some other
time because it's a completely different
discussion addictive relationships why
did one of the most beautiful women of
ever known who came into my early Refuge
said to me eron if I hear his voice I'll
be like the P Piper and I'll go back I
didn't know how to help her and I was
away on holiday and she left me a letter
so when I came back when she was dead
she did go back and she did die wow and
having said that I used to have a
picture of a man and he was in his
coffin and when I was working with men
I'd often just show them that picture
and say and where do you think you're
going to be if you don't get out and
they'd say yeah it sh kill them yeah
rather that or still push him to where
he kills himself the response is always
well men are stronger couldn't couldn't
he just but they're not stronger pH
emotionally they're certainly not we're
far Stronger Yeah I wouldn't even say
stronger I think we're almost more
manipulative but that makes you stronger
you have you you you can maneuver your
way around all sorts of situations yeah
in a way I've always found men to be
fairly straightforward but that's why I
like working with women much more
interesting what do you think could be
done to improve the situation for male
abuse victims refugees first start there
aren't any there's one I think that I
saw and it was brilliant and I just a
fog so I think it was in Denmark and it
it worked very very well they could take
10 men with their children that's the
only one I've ever really known but but
as a whole if the government is prepared
to supply this enormous amounts of money
for female refugees why won't they do it
for male refugees well partly because
there's no male organization trying to
get refuges for men do you think there's
any stopping feminism at this point I
think younger women have recognized the
hostility that it's created and the
majority of young people that I know
women don't call themselves feminists
and if it does it means what we were all
fool because we were told this was going
to be Equity feminism equal feminism for
instance people didn't know if you
wanted contraception you had to prove to
the doctor that you were going to get
married otherwise you have usually what
they did that sounds like a good
thing I mean it's better than the only
fans we got now you know what I
mean so and the other thing was that if
you wanted for instance if you had money
of your own and you wanted a mortgage
you had to get your father or your
husband to sign for you with you I'll
tell you what I'll tell you what all
these women with 100K of student debt
for the rest of their lives yeah they
probably could have benefited from that
you know for a while I used to think
this stuff sounded crazy but the older I
get the more I think maybe there's a
reason they did that stuff that way you
know way um so where you had to ask get
married in order to get birth control
where you had to you couldn't um you
just said you couldn't get a loan or
something you need to get your that's
morgage or a mortgage and the older I
get the more I think maybe there was a
reason they had these stuff things in
place it was because it was almost for
our own good um not saying you go back
to that or anything but you know now
it's like I look at the average
30-year-old woman she usually has a lot
of debt she's usually not married um no
children no children um not typically a
great relationship with her family um
and so I kind of think like what maybe
but but look at the forces and look at
the hostility that women showed towards
even the profession of being married and
and the idea that you know we were we
and I remember that those early days you
have no idea what it was like because
they had these huge meetings you know in
kton Hall and you'd have a thousand
women in there screaming and ranting
about women's lot and all the rest of it
and I'd stand on the stage with my tiny
little group and we we'd try and reason
but there was no reason it was women
could have everything women are exactly
like men see I I sat I I always said
scratch a woman and you'll find find a
three-piece Suite most women want to get
married most women want to have children
and most people men and women really at
the end of the day want to love and be
love it's really that simple but look
what we've done with it I would pay to
watch
that a thousand
women I go you know sometimes I'll go to
those organizations like the feminist
meetups yeah I went to one the other day
I just thought it was funny and there
was like an abortion one these women
want to kill their kids so bad I'm like
this is so crazy and they're taking
quite question so I just like I had a
question and I and I asked them I'm like
why do you guys want to kill your kids
so bad and they all just looked at me
like I was crazy I'm like what like this
just seems and I told him I'm like this
just seems like a lot I'm like maybe
don't have sex with someone you don't
want to have a kid with they thought I
was nuts I was like I have a solution
for everybody but but you're not allowed
to do that you're not allowed to say
that these are the unsayable things
aren't they one of them is for women is
the one that I think so interesting is
why aren't you taking responsib ability
for yourself try saying that you nearly
get murdered well yeah and then I they
said they were like well women don't get
abortions for no reason and I'm like
well they get abortions for a lot of
stupid reasons I'm like but the problem
is wom been using abortion as a form of
contraception I know someone that had
seven I know I've talked to women who
had four or five yeah and I'm like how
you guys didn't learn your lesson the
first second third fourth
fifth yeah and and now with proper
contraception there's no excuse you know
it was different when I was young
because there wasn't any contraception
and again and then finally when that
when it did come into into use as as
I've said you know the doctors made the
decisions about who could have it and
how and when MH um my feeling is there
needs that there needs to be a real
shakeer of relationships and the trouble
is you can't say oh well we'll have to
go back you can't put the genie back in
the BX we have to spiral into an
alternative way of looking at
relationship ship with each other you
know what I think's going to happen I
think women are going to start paying
for men I I think that surprise me I
think you're going to start seeing men
that are young realize that they're
basically being discriminated against
for jobs they're being discriminated
against in school there's these women
really I would argue with a lot of
useless jobs getting paid a lot so like
example in Tech they just hire you
because you're a woman and give you six
figures high paying Human Resources jobs
all of these jobs where women just think
they're so much more special and
important than we really are in the
workforce my opinion and I think there's
some guys that are going to look at the
market realize they can just get jacked
learn how to cook and date a woman 10
years older than them yeah men are kind
of logical and you have all these women
that didn't have kids and I'm like
they're the guys are going to think well
if I have a kid with somebody then you
know she can take all of my stuff it
might just be easier be a stay at home
Dad I think it's going to be a new
Dynamic and I'm seeing it more and more
like we had a lawyer come on the show
her husband's a musician obviously who's
making the money you know what I mean
like yeah and I I think it's going to be
a dynamic and then the women will
complain about that too they'll be like
we wanted to work and then they did and
then they'll cry what a world right
Aaron it was it was entirely
unfortunately predictable I have huge
and then you young women and it's not
going to be the same have to be honest I
[Laughter]
don't well pendulum swings as pendulum
does I hope I hope you're right though I
think I've just interviewed one too many
only fans models to
really to be hopeful do you know what I
mean but thank you so much for coming on
eron um it's a pleasure it's always a
pleasure having you here I look forward
to talking to you later on at sometime
um when when I'm a 100 that's near 100
yeah I actually I want to interview um a
couple that's been married for over 50
years I don't know if you know any I'm
just trying to think I will think and
I'll get in touch with you if I can
think of anybody I've also got to want
to do it as well yeah because I I think
it would be good you know we don't
really see that much anymore those are
the models that you want yeah um do you
want to tell the people do you have
YouTube or you on anything nope I was
like I don't know at 84 if you do
that I mean I use YouTube I'm not on
anything actually I know I um yeah I
mean I I've never really been I'm just
me okay well thank you for coming on
Aaron um all right guys um make sure you
like the video on your way out and
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell um also get yourself a
women shouldn't vote t-shirt you know I
know there's these feminists that say
women should vote I'm of the opinion
that they should not vote and then we
should take it away so get yourself a
t-shirt we'll talk to you next time I